in leipzig habe ich diese woche mit
starkoch tim raue gesprochen er hat
schon mehrere auszeichnungen bekommen
ist zwei sterne koch hat mehrere tv
shows und ist ein berliner ghetto kind
ja es ist wirklich in berlin groß
geworden bei einer straßenlänge hatte
nichts hat sich hochgearbeitet und bis
jetzt einer der besten köche im
fernsehen muss man sagen
[Musik]
leider war es halt bei mir so dass mein
vater mich als als kind oder
jugendlicher richtig übel verdroschen
hat ohne dass ich damals in irgendeiner
form mist gebaut hätte oder dass man das
irgendwie hätte rechtfertigen können und
ich bin dann vom opfer später zum täter
geworden
ich habe mir freunde gesucht mit denen
ich gewalttätig geworden bin
glücklicherweise haben wir jetzt nicht
unbehelligte menschen auf der straße
einfach angegriffen sondern wir haben
uns gleichgesinnte gesucht aber auch das
ist was was ich natürlich mit dem
heutigen tag oder jetzt einfach scheiße
finde ich habe mich mehrfach dafür
entschuldigt was ich da getan habe was
ich angerichtet habe aber seit teil
meiner meiner geschichte auf der anderen
seite habe ich früh im leben gelernt
mich durchzukämpfen durchzuboxen und
tatsächlich auch zu leiden
das ist was was mir jetzt gerade in der
krise mal wieder hilft also diese
existenzielle druck der ist etwas was
mich mein ganzes leben antreibt
außerdem wollte ich von hinnen wissen
aber lieber für sich selbst kocht oder
andere bekocht was ich tatsächlich bis
heute nicht geschafft habe auch in
aktuellen gesprächstherapien ist spaß
daran zu haben für mich zu kochen ich
komme immer noch tatsächlich für mich
als letztes und ich bin lieber gast als
dass ich selber für mich kochen fällt
mir unfassbar schwer einen salat
zusammen zu schnippeln in zwei minuten
um den dann selber zu essen bestelle ich
mir lieber was oder am allerliebsten
gehe ich essen ehrlicherweise das mag
ich besonders gerne im raum zu sein der
wuselig ist wo ich nicht mehr
mittelpunkt stehe sich keine sau
eigentlich für mich interessiert und ich
einen leckeren wein trinken kann was
schönes essen kann und einfach
beobachten kann wieso mich herum das
leben wird viert und vibriert wir alle
wissen tim hat natürlich mehrere
restaurants und die sind gar zu weswegen
ein lieferservice ja aber aktuell sind
sie zu und wer die ganze corona sache
sieht hat ein talent ich glaube dass wir
in unserer gesellschaft in den letzten
zehn jahren einen einen konsum überfluss
hatten der unfassbar war wir sind von a
nach b geflogen einfach mal am
wochenende sechs stunden
flieger dubai angucken wieder zurück wir
haben uns t shirts und pullis gekauft
die zur einfachsten sachen einfachsten
preisen hergestellt werden wo einfachen
namen drauf gebaut wurde und anstatt 99
hat das ding 1620 euro gekostet und wir
haben überhaupt gar keine relation mehr
gehabt wer wäre haben sind so auf
unseren wohlstand fixiert dass das unser
größtes gut ist und jetzt haben wir eine
situation wo es darum geht dass gerade
die älteren und die schwachen menschen
leiden müssen und unsere regierung halt
auch zeigt dass die politiker sind sie
sind keine unternehmer das heißt sie
sind nicht besonders flexibel im
denkmuster sie kennen zwar krisen aber
sie müssen jetzt ein ganzes land auch
wirtschaftlich im endeffekt
perspektivisch führen
und da gibt es gibt meines erachtens
viel korrekturbedarf eigentlich aber die
grundsätzliche haltung kann ja auch so
verkehrt nicht sein über die gastronomie
ist halt schwierig weil sie die branche
ist die am meisten investiert hat in
diesem jahr vor allen dingen weil es um
sicherheitskonzepte ging und wir haben
alles gemacht wir haben alles
mitgetragen und jetzt wieder geschlossen
zu werden halte ich tatsächlich eher für
ein fehler weil die menschen sich privat
treffen und das einräumen die halt
überhaupt gar kein sicherheitskonzept
haben und das merke ich auch in meinem
umfeld das merke ich natürlich auch wenn
wir essen ausliefern
auf wie viele portionen wir ausliefern
und auf wen wir da treffen im moment
haben wir ein problem mit der
solidarität da geht es darum dass jeder
demütigen halben schritt zurück gehen
muss etwas was ich von meinem großvater
gelernt habe sich selber mal nicht so
wichtig nimmt und dass das entscheidende
ist dass wir als gemeinschaft sehr gut
funktionieren das machen wir schon in
deutschland besser als in den meisten
anderen ländern
aber da bin ich dann halt ganz derjenige
der es immer verbessern möchte und noch
besser machen möchte
wir können da durchaus zulegen